hi my name is
i'm 13 years old i'm noah schnapp i'm 10
years old my name is emily brown i'm 11
years old i'm finn wolfhard i'm sick my
name is kate matarazzo and i'm 12 years
old the journey to casting stranger
things was a long one but thousands of
auditions later the duffer brothers were
able to land on the iconic cast we know
today however that doesn't mean that the
cast landed the part they originally
wanted in fact a lot of actors including
the og stranger things cast were at
first rejected ready to find out why
we'll have to see
skyler gartner's experience auditioning
for stranger things is the definition of
everything happens for a reason the
young actor says he auditioned for not
one but two characters in stranger
things he never mentioned what parts
they were but we're going to take a wild
guess and say will and mike but skyler
never heard back from the casting
director and moved on the stranger
things rejection was a blessing in
disguise because without it he wouldn't
have auditioned and landed his huge role
in another hit show ozark chaos never
stops the stranger things auditions even
reached as far as broadway where stage
star eli tokash took a shot at getting a
place in the upside down he spoke about
his audition with stranger things season
3 actor gabriela pizzolo on his podcast
saying although he did send in a tape he
never got a call back this just goes to
show just how selective the duffer
brothers were with the casting of the
series
hi i'm noah schnapp and i play will
byers at this point imagining anyone
else but finn wolfhard playing mike is
impossible but at one point the duffer
brothers did have to do this with noah
schnapp yup noah originally auditioned
for mike instead of will when he sent in
his audition tape he was obviously
rejected for the part of mike but got a
call while at camp from the production
team letting him know they wanted to
cast him as will i actually auditioned
for mike first then they called me back
for will we're not sure noah even
realized he was offered a different part
at that point according to the actor he
had auditioned for so many jobs he
couldn't place what role he had just
landed i was like oh my god wait so this
is like this is my first tv show joe
kiri was looking to play a more relaxed
character than the one he ended up
portraying when he first sent in an
audition tape it was for jonathan byers
basically the complete opposite of steve
harrington after not getting a call back
he assumed he just didn't get the role
he was right but they still called and
asked if he would consider sending in a
tape for steve instead
i said
yeah
although joe remembers thinking how much
of a total jerk steve was he sent in the
tape and the rest is history at least in
the end joe did get to experience
steve's character development and got
the best of both worlds by playing jerk
steve and nice steve they don't tell you
about that when they cast you being an
established actor the duffer brothers
were a little taken back when they
received an audition tape from sean
astin usually actors like shawn are
offered the part or an audition instead
of just sending in a tape but sean was
just such a huge fan of the show that he
wanted to be a part of it in any way he
could casting older and more experienced
actors it's a big responsibility the
tape he sent in was originally for a
journalist named murray bowman who would
only be featured in four season two
episodes however the duffer brothers
thought his fame would be a little too
distracting for the role and had to
reject him but that wasn't without them
calling shawn and offering him the part
of bob newby instead
i'm newbie superhero
in a way even the duffer brothers had to
audition and face rejection before they
were given an opportunity to shine they
went through almost 20 networks until
netflix finally lit the match on their
projects apparently others were having a
hard time grasping whether stranger
things was for adults or children isn't
that the beauty of it it's not meant for
one group and not the other i mean it's
kind of a it's meant for everybody once
they were cast themselves they went on
to audition 907 boys and 307 girls for
the roles of the hawkins gang the entire
audition process consisted of the actors
reading lines from the stranger things
season 1 script and lines from the movie
stand by me which was a major
inspiration for the brothers but not
every audition was that straightforward
earlier we spoke about some of the
actors who were rejected from a role on
the show but there are some members of
the stranger things cast who got the
part in the end but had to go as far as
lying to be cast and were very nearly
rejected in the process it's very kind
of unique directing this young cat i
love it believe it or not the duffer
brothers didn't automatically think of
winona ryder as their first choice for
joyce they were really vying on casting
huge adult stars to draw in a variety of
audience members and were looking at
both naomi watts and marissa tomei
instead however in the end winona's
electric energy won out the duffer
brothers admitted that they considered
her an option after realizing how much
they missed seeing her on the big screen
as you probably suspected winona didn't
have a traditional audition instead they
invited her to have tea and a chat with
the production unit we sat for hours
having tea with winona and we came away
from those interactions with certainty
that we've found our hopper and our
joists apparently sitting across from
winona gave off the vibe and atmosphere
they were looking for in their perfect
choice
if you can't handle this then just turn
around and drop me up first david
harbour wasn't anywhere on the duffer
brothers radar in the early stages of
casting for stranger things in fact
there were two actors ahead of him on
the list that the brothers had their eye
out for just like winona because
stranger things was originally meant to
be a limited series the casting
department wanted to try to utilize the
star power of either ewan mcgregor or
sam rockwell to draw in adult audiences
but casting director carmen cuba wasn't
having that she pushed and pushed for
david and when it was decided that
netflix wouldn't be a limited series and
the duffer brothers saw his audition
tape they knew that he would be the
perfect fit for the scruffy fun-loving
sheriff they had created carmen i'll
give her full credit because she just
kept going i think david harbor ewan
mcgregor had nothing on david harbor by
the end of it
yes i think
it worked
sadie started off as just another fan of
the show before she landed her audition
for stranger things but the young
actress went to long lengths that almost
had a catastrophic end just to land the
role of max after binge watching season
1 of the series and becoming obsessed
she asked her agent to get her an
audition and a week later she was
standing in the audition room in front
of the casting directors however before
the interview she had told them that she
was an avid rollerblader which turned
bad fast i was doing some scenes and all
of a sudden i look into the corner of
the room and see a pair of rollerblades
i'm like holy crap they're going to make
me rollerblade i kept thinking oh no oh
no
luckily they didn't make her rollerblade
and she landed the role but she did have
to face the consequences of actually
learning how to rollerblade before
filming started it turned out great they
needed a certain type of personality to
be able to portray billy with all of his
emotionally charged scenes and snarky
attitude stranger things couldn't cast
just anyone that's why it isn't exactly
a surprise how different daker
montgomery's audition tape was while it
starts out fairly normal with him
reading lines and giving it his all he
ends the audition by dancing shirtless
with a pair of sunglasses to the song
come on eileen an 80s staple while in
hindsight it may seem a little odd it's
very on par for billy's character and it
landed him the role it just goes to show
what kind of effort needed to be put
into these auditions in order to
actually land a role on the hit netflix
series
kind of went all out um but i believe in
taking risks getting rejected isn't fun
but if the experience of these actors
can teach us anything it's that
sometimes getting rejected leads us to
something even greater without joe kiri
getting rejected we wouldn't have the
sassy steve harrington we all love so
much
what audition story is your favorite
thanks for watching